Drive is a film that was at first
initially polarizing for the average
film goer where most film critics and
enthusiasts hailed it as one of the best
films of the year audiences were largely
perplexed the most common complaint was
that the film was boring and didn't
contain enough action sequences Brown
Tomatoes holds the film at 93 percent
whereas cinema score a poll that
aggregates the general audience reaction
gave the film a c-minus in my opinion
these complaints are result of two
things marketing and false expectations
one might even argue that those two are
interconnected people see a trailer for
a movie called drive where Ryan Gosling
plays a getaway driver they see fast
shots of car chases and Gosling ready to
pound a bullet into a man's head and
they immediately think ooh that looks
cool and oh my god Ryan Gosling the guy
from The Notebook people don't know what
winning the Best Director award at pecan
Film Festival means or who Nicolas
Winding ref and even is and they don't
care to look as a result film lovers
were in total ecstasy and the average
ticket buyers were infuriated by only
two car chases lots of romance and slow
building tension and the guy from The
Notebook being really violent one
idiotic woman even tried to sue the
filmmakers of drive for its lack of
action drive is my favorite film that
came out in 2011 and much like my
Prometheus explained video I want to go
in-depth with the film and explain to
you all why I think it's a very
important movie and perhaps persuade
those who dismissed it initially to give
it another go Drive opens with a scene
that is meant to introduce us
immediately to the character of the
driver by showing us his world where
he's most comfortable and how meticulous
he is this is the scene that virtually
everyone who saw the film loved because
it's what they expected it didn't
surprise them it's an opening action
scene although very different from most
which I'll get to in a second in one
shot we learned so much about this man
he has his route already mapped out we
hear him list his rules
five minutes only no guns we see the
Scorpion jacket which besides looking
ultra badass has significance to the
story we'll talk about that later we see
a basketball game on the TV which is
very important to the end of this scene
the chromatics
tick of the clock song pulses in the
background and we pan in on the city of
los angeles we meet his boss Shannon
played typically marvelously by Bryan
Cranston he supplies him with his
getaway car and were immediately into
one of the most suspenseful opening
scenes in recent memory besides the
perfect lighting and cinematography
immaculate editing and timing what's
most unique about this opening chase and
what most people miss is that the camera
never leaves the vehicle this was done
to show the perspective of the character
rather than Hollywood eyes the action so
to speak the driver continues to listen
to the same basketball game that was on
the TV earlier and successfully times
his escape perfectly to match the
screaming crowds of fans leaving the
stadium after this scene Kavinsky
futuristic song night call and the city
of la boum onto the screen and one of
the best opening credits sequences I've
ever seen proceeds I feel like I'd be
being a dead horse to se the soundtrack
for this film is euphoric it introduced
me to a whole different genre of music I
have now come to love after the opening
credits for many people this is where
the film slows down we see the
meticulous driver doing stunt work for a
film where he first puts on the body
cast masks and we meet Irene his
neighbor who he strikes up a
relationship with that emotionless face
from the intro begins to soften and we
begin to see his dark world getting a
little brighter later the driver looks
out the window seeing Irene and her son
Benicio walking we don't get the
standard close-up of the actors but we
see them from a distance to me this
highlighted the driver is longing to be
in a normal world and just how far away
from that he felt next we made Bernie
Rose played terrifically by Albert
Brooks who shaved his eyebrows for the
role in an attempt to look as
emotionless as
possible Nino played by Ron Perlman is
also introduced in this scene here
Shannon is able to convince Bernie to
give the driver a look in the interest
of him driving a stock car that he wants
to purchase in the next scene we get
another brief look at the drivers
talents and his first encounter with
rose as well as one of the best lines in
the film which perfectly sums up both
characters good I want you to meet mr.
Bernie Rose my hands are a little dirty
so online when Irene and Benicio later
visit driver at the repair shop he works
at once again you can see him start to
light up almost like a little boy with a
crush when they go riding together we
hear what has become known as the film's
main theme a real hero a song with
lyrics telling the tale of a man
standing up for what's right even when
everything is on the line this song is
drastically important to the film and
the reason it's first played in this
scene is because the bond that's created
here between these three characters is
what leads to the driver eventually
becoming the better person he wants to
be more on that later what comes next is
a brief montage highlighting the
continuing relationship between driver
and Irene and we can tell that this
hardened man is starting to finally see
a light at the end of the tunnel a way
out of the shady world he lives in next
Bernie visits the repair shop to talk
more about driver racing for him and
after a story explaining Shannon's limp
you can tell the driver doesn't trust
Bernie this is brilliant storytelling
because you can learn all of this about
drivers simply by examining his facial
expressions it's great acting on
goslings part now in this next scene a
conversation between driver and Benicio
takes place that could easily be
dismissed as random chitchat but in a
film this meticulously crafted
everything matters
see bad guy yeah how can you tell
because he's a shark
there's no good chucks no I mean just
look at him he look like good guy to you
to me that was in reference to driver
he's a shark he's a bad guy he wants to
know if there are any good sharks and
when Benicio seems to think otherwise he
suddenly gets this look like reality hit
him drive is loaded with little gems
like this that harsh reality continues
into the next scene where driver learns
that Irene's husband is coming home from
prison his world which was finally
starting to look bright is starting to
crumble when standard is released from
jail they have a welcome home party
where he thanks his wife for waiting for
him driver works on a car part in his
dark apartment hearing the base of the
song under your spell in the background
as standard toast his wife she is
clearly thinking about driver and when
we return to him the song is now in the
foreground connecting the two characters
briefly in their United moment of
longing for each other at this point
driver is starting to feel like he has
nothing he already wanted out of the
criminal life but the one bright spot
that was starting to form was now gone
it's here that we first start to see the
anger brewing the first hints at what
he's truly capable of doing someone that
driver pulled a job for in the past
suddenly recognizes him at a restaurant
and tries to make some idle chitchat
with some very bad results I'm not this
shut you mouth well kick your teeth down
you through and I'll shut it for you
drivers world takes another turn for the
worst when standard is threatened and
forced into robbing a local pawn shop
Benicio is given a bullet by a goon
named cook which driver keeps for later
but you can continuously see driver
becoming increasingly unstable as he
thinks of this family and harm after
some thinking driver agrees to help
standard pull this last job with his
only
is being to leave Irene and Benicio
alone he's got his jacket on again
almost like it's his superhero costume
here we also meet Blanche for the first
time now the next few scenes are
relatively straightforward the heist
goes wrong an incredible chasing takes
place and Driver and Blanche escape to a
nearby motel now it's funny is these are
the scenes people wanted more of but
they're the ones that I have the least
to say about they promote the lease
discussion they're awesomely well
crafted and entertaining as hell for
sure
but it says something about the
expectations of today's average audience
member in the motel driver and Blanche
here on the news that the pawnshop owner
denied any money having been stolen and
with the death of standard the second
unknown car being at the heist and
Blanche's obvious deception driver
starts his descent into darkness now I'd
like to believe that throughout this
film so far driver thinks of himself as
a good guy at least that's what he wants
to be and it's during the bloody
massacre that happens next that driver
has a nasty realization he is not the
good guy at least not yet anyway that's
why this next shot is one of the best in
the film to me it's the shot where the
weight of drivers actions
finally hits him and he sees the true
horror of this life that he chooses to
live in
even before all of this goes down driver
looks like a scared boy
I believe that up until now he's been
successful in his criminal undertakings
with no problems of whatsoever
nevertheless driver has snapped a little
inside and he can think of nothing but
where to find cook and it's in this next
scene where something amazing happens at
least is for me anyway I'm watching a
scene with a room full of boobs and my
attention is focused elsewhere the
timing of the shots the use of pauses
and the masterful forced perspective of
driver the camera always being below him
showing his mastery over the situation
make this one of the best scenes in the
entire film
so driver gets in contact with Nino and
all he wants to do is give the stolen
money back to him and Nino sends a thug
after him which oddly resembles Joseph
gordon-levitt and looper some reason to
me I don't know if anyway now in this
next scene I believe that driver is at
his lowest point and possibly the entire
movie I'll explain why as I said earlier
in a film this carefully crafted nothing
is left to chance
drivers collar is crooked throughout
this entire scene where he explains
everything to Irene his hair is for the
first time disheveled he's no longer
this composed calm person that he's been
for the majority of the movie he just
wants to have a normal life with this
family but the criminal world keeps
pulling him back in and when Irene isn't
responsive to drivers pleading he
perhaps feels like he has no hope left
this leads to the infamous elevator
scene where the thug Nino sent shows up
upon seeing the gun driver realizes this
will be his last moment with Irene
before she sees him for what he is he
kisses her slowly and then completely
snaps in his mind he no longer has Irene
the one thing that was helping him
become that better person he wants to be
he no longer wants to be a criminal and
now both of those things aren't going
his away he takes all of this out on
this man and has seen many called
unnecessarily violent I disagree this
violence has a deep meaning to the story
it isn't just blood and guts for the
hell
as driver probably predicted Irene now
sees him for what he is and his reaction
once again to what he's done is almost
like a surprise child the elevator doors
close almost separating them
indefinitely
the last shot in this scene is a
breathtaking close-up of the Scorpion
why is that this has to do with the
significance of the Scorpion which I
alluded to in the beginning of this
video I'll come back to this later next
driver is naturally curious how they
found him and learns that Shannan very
stupidly spilled the beans on Irene and
him after starting to snap again he
calms himself and tells Shannan he has
to get out notice drivers collar is
still crooked now Nino and Bernie argue
about the crap they're into and cook
meets a rather gruesome death at the
hands of Bernie but he does it to make a
point he wants Nino to clean up his mess
because now Bernie has to do that as
well you learn more about these two
villains in this scene and what's great
is how humanized the baddies are in this
movie they've got real problems too and
this is besides the point but every time
I watch this scene I'm reminded how much
I love Ron Perlman that guy's awesome
now we return to driver the next day and
he seems to have composure of himself
again he has a plan of some kind some
have made fun of the stupidity of
walking around with blood all over
yourself but people seem to not realize
that he's on a movie set now about to
steal the body cast mask
he'd probably fit right in as driver
warned Burnie comes for Shannon he gives
up his hopes of having his name on a car
and kill Shannon quickly Albert Brooks
said that one of the things that
attracted him to the part was that he
wasn't just some ruthless killer it
affected him it saddened him he didn't
like it we see that after Shannon's
death after finding Shannon dead and
clearly wanting revenge driver Don's the
mask to kill Nino and many have wondered
why he does that why does he approach
the door and look in only to get back in
his car why does he over dramatically
stare at Nino on the beach why doesn't
he just kill him and get it over with
let me steal a quote from Ryan Gosling
he said basically when I read it I'm
trying to figure out who would do
something like this
the only way to make sense of this is
that this guy has seen too many movies
and he's starting to confuse his life
for a film he's lost in the mythology of
Hollywood and he's become an
amalgamation of all the characters that
he admires others have brought up this
idea before I'm not the first to say
this but it seems like here driver
begins to savor the moment a little
Irene's gone he knows that there's no
way out of this situation he's going
about this like a superhero donning a
costume walking around like a badass
he's loving every moment of terrifying
Nino on the beach until he kills him in
the ocean a very movie like setting this
is just a theory I believe to be
accurate he could just wear the mask
because he doesn't want to risk being
seen by all the possible thugs in Minos
restaurant while planning a final meet
between himself and Bernie Driver
mentions the story of the Scorpion and
the Frog it's an old tale about a
scorpion asking a frog to carry him
across the river the Frog is afraid that
he will be stung by the scorpion but the
Scorpion says that if he were to sting
him the Frog would sink killing them
both halfway across the river the
scorpion does sting the Frog and they
both drown
scorpion admits it's in his nature to
sting the point of the fable is that it
illustrates that some creatures or
people do what is in their instinct to
do no matter how they are treated or
what the consequences are they cannot
escape their destiny some have had many
ideas of what that means for the film to
me I see it as a perfect description of
drivers desires to be a better person he
wants to be with Irene he wants to
change but he can't escape the life that
he's lived and he eventually stings her
and himself as a result dooming them
both as I mentioned earlier I believe
this is why the Scorpion gets a close-up
at the end of the elevator scene he's
now stung Irene and completely doomed
their relationship there was no going
back after that moment of course this is
just my interpretation of what it means
to the movie there
many other possibilities but this is the
one that I feel fits the story the most
he now only has one chance to set things
right he makes a final phone call to
Irene telling her that she and Benicio
was the best thing that ever happened to
him and then he goes to meet Bernie
Bernie gives him an ultimatum give up
the money and Irene is safe forever but
driver will always be looking over his
shoulder to me this is where driver sees
his opportunity he can finally become
that better person he wants to be it may
not be in the best circumstances but he
can get out Irene is safe and it will be
because of him now just before Bernie
stabs driver outside we see a shot of
him in the restaurant with a look of I
know what you're going to do I
personally think driver had the up on
Bernie this whole time because when
driver gets stabbed he doesn't have a
look of shock it's like he knew it was
coming then we return to the restaurant
again and Driver smiles he's got this
whole thing planned already he stabs
Bernie back with a knife he could have
only had so quickly if he knew what was
coming now we get what was for me one of
the most excruciating ly suspenseful
moments I've ever seen in a movie driver
stares into space for what seems like
ever until you finally begin to hear the
real hero song playing in the background
ever so faintly finally he blinks and
starts up the car driving away he
protected Irene and Benicio killed all
the bad guys and even left the money
behind he has finally become the hero he
wanted to be and he drives off into the
night to me this is the perfect ending
this film could have had then there are
some people who've seen inception too
many times who think that the last shot
of him driving is him dead or going into
heaven or something now he still got the
blood on his hand pal he's alive plus
there's this whole second book being
published called driven and winding
reference stating that the character
might show up in other films so yeah it
seems a little silly to think that he
would be dead it doesn't really seem
like the story would then work so I hope
you enjoyed my take on Drive and perhaps
you see the film differently now
I tend to look at films from the
standpoint of the director and I try to
get inside his head space here I feel
this is one of the best directed films
I've ever seen I want to apologize for
initially giving this film an A and
without a doubt deserves my highest
rating of eight plus it's one of my
all-time favorite films